[Music]
and car security news submitted by
Enterprise rent-a-car we swing by who
enterprise rent-a-car enterprise okay
this is unfortunately by this this is
talking about enterprise rent-a-car bad
PR still good PR all PR is good PR
because this thing is back here
sometimes it's still bad personal
references okay so a renter rented a car
from enterprise rent-a-car who is a Ford
Escape
I believe Ford Expedition and through
Ford the Ford Expedition you can have
something called Ford Pass which is like
a app on your phone that allows you to
connect to your car and manually unlock
it start the car do a whole bunch of
stuff track the car and it sounds
expensive I don't think I can afford it
okay yeah anyway so he thought it was a
cool idea so he liked that it was a that
he was able to do all these neat little
things with it news is cool and so then
he stopped the rental um you know return
the car and everything like that and he
signed back into the app you know just
out of curiosity like hey I can still
control all the things that I was out
able to control and so then he contacted
Ford he was like hey by the way you have
all these like fleet cars you know that
are you sold to enterprise that can do
that but I could still track all of this
stuff you might want to do something
about it and then five months later for
it's still not done anything see you so
he's been posting on Twitter he's like I
can stole you know tragedies like
posting screenshots of like seeing where
the car is like in real time cuz he can
still see exactly where the car went
that's calm and then he was like maybe
I'll just and then he's like tweeting I
was like maybe I'm just gonna start
unlocking the car for funsies now like
kind of is like a slight you know just
about the ass got something a
tongue-in-cheek kind of threat to Ford
it's like hey fix your [ __ ] you know
like stop you know hey thanks yeah so if
I was him I would made like a whole meme
page guessing where's that car now
saying like oh I'm here action how would
be I don't think you can drive the car
the adventures and the adventures and
days of whatever the car is no okay yeah
hey good marketing where you can see it
you can turn it off he can track for you
or for them no for the page the mean
page yeah so he's been tracking it so
he's been able to access this in June
apparently and so he says that the
rental agreement that he signed is
pretty vague let's still on right now I
don't know this is this article was
posted end of October so hopefully they
fixed it by now but there he's saying so
at first he start kind of started off by
saying how cool the app is and
everything like that but it don't know
that I would use this and I don't know
that I like the way that Ford has
implemented this system especially in a
rental car
so you know what's funny is that I've
worked with a security company before
and caramba carumba know they're all
about like cyber security and things
like that and one of the commercial or
the main commercial that like we have
we've been recurring and remaking is
like a car like a car hacker hmm and so
there are hackers now who can access
your car via like all your Bluetooth in
the internet of things and how it's all
connecting to your vehicle like my phone
currently knows where my car's parked
because it was connected through
bluetooth and now it's like okay well
this [ __ ] yeah so now hackers are
starting to access cars and like pay me
this much or we're gonna run your we're
gonna do we're gonna disengage your
brain oh yeah or something that [ __ ]
yeah that's like what I've done two or
three commercials with them and it's
like the Caramba is supposed to be like
the the security system or like a like a
like a essentially like a firewall for
you they're providing the solution
solution to makes more hackers yeah yeah
that's like yeah it won't be a will be
hacked because I won't do it yeah
exactly
that's the idea that was a whole hope
it's not the idea it's like ransomware
you know when they hack in your computer
and they're just like oh pay me like ten
thousand dollars and I'll unlock your
computer and I won't delete everything
on it yeah we're all so sick encrypt
everything and you won't be able to get
any of it back yeah it's the same idea
just for the car
yeah great yeah that's safety right
there it's like you can contact spouses
of like somebody who's driving and have
them like my god yeah yo that's a
[ __ ] movie [ __ ] know that it swear to
god that that's a commercial like maybe
cutting your husband's breaks right now
yeah just a dude hanging on the other
side of the car turning right no turning
left right we go yeah I guess I'm
keeping my Jeep Wrangler then yeah just
a super legit angler with no power
windows or power love it I'll just have
to break into it the old-fashioned way
through the soft top and just rip it
open we're gonna be like Will Smith in
the IRA but it's crazy because I
remember back when remember when OnStar
was like first a thing when they first
announced that I'm sorry and they were
giving you the option to the OnStar
could remotely start or stop your car
like in case you lost your keys or they
can remotely unlock your car get your
OnStar number or whatever and I remember
shoutouts that's the guy my dad he was
like oh [ __ ] that I don't like that
somebody to [ __ ] be able to turn off
my car and like hack into it and stuff
and at the time like [ __ ] like
10-year old me was just like I mean fast
words for the future I'm like well he
was on one he was I think it's like very
it's very tricky to do something like
that because I think if you were to
definitely do that you have to one go
through their server and you'd have to
find like a like back wall so now that
you do that you teach us about hacking
right now is no never
I just said it was difficult you're
explaining in a very easy manner I'm
saying directly speaking very sneaky
it is not theoretical it is happening do
jailbreak iPhones is that you're hacking
experience we just discussed that it is
happening now you can remotely say yes
sir now you're ready what do you mean
I'm saying yes it's a thing no I'm not
gonna say yes or no to Shawn's question
oh yes but I'm saying you got to go
through the server but then you have to
use probably like a via this a VPN to
mask yourself and then you got to then
go through that whole process being kind
of specific and then being extremely
vague like yeah there's a whole process
to hacking first you got to get a VPN
and then you just hack it it's a big
risk and I think it remember Linux
software I think I think that a hacker
that's that advanced it's able to get
into someone's [ __ ] car and figure
out all this stuff has figured out feel
like this is just an easy like you know
dummies guide to hacking kind of guy
that's like Morgan's you could do this
yeah that's your point that hacking is
more difficult than it sounds happens I
don't think it's that difficult to
explain to me what what are you telling
us I'm just saying that it would be very
very really tricky yeah difficult what
can I say what can I say shrieking all
right Josh jailbreaking this phone
it's like [ __ ] Mandy that we do a JK
party games like don't mention fast
games games in history remote ah yeah um
last week
Oh past tense sometime the history I've
never played it before sometimes you
played it like this so since you have
since you've worked for a company that
provides like firewall services for cars
but you also have a car that can be you
know subject to they use kind of like
hacking if you have it yeah do you do
you have like a service that like
protects your car how does it make you
feel though as far as like owning a car
that has that ability to be like messed
with I guess
well not Jesus I mean it's interesting
because I mean I'll just say as we were
shooting it the driver had to
specifically like like over the wheel
and like let it go crazy I was in the
the back of the car while we're shooting
like cameras by the cameras in the front
seat I'm in the back seat recording the
audio and I'm recording this guy like
freaking out and we're having to like
mimic a car jolting back and forth even
being in control of that situation is
still scary as [ __ ] and just those
conditions it's alone imagine like all
of a sudden your [ __ ] starts to go
haywire your gas pedal isn't working
because everything's electrical now
right your brakes are on an electrical
system it's no longer brake fluid dude
because everyone Prius is first which
took computers hundreds of people people
died yes a toyota thing yeah so - yo -
switch to no longer yeah and then they
first start putting computers and the
problem was that they had a single
computer controlling things now that
they have three computers for it to
cross-reference right yeah because that
was a problem before and what would
happen is that like cosmic rays because
it's always rays coming down from
mercury in retrograde and what happened
was it would hit a single bit that
controlled like the bricks or a gas and
it would hit the single bit and flip it
on and now gas is going and you can't
stop the car and like hundreds of people
died and it wasn't until a I think that
he was a veteran or something he and he
was a police officer police officer he
was on you know police officer he was on
the phone with 911 one right full car
five people and then he's like the car
is not stopping we're going like a
hundred miles an hour we're about to
approach an intersection and then often
you hear him start praying and then it
goes boom gone oh yeah
and that's when it like it went so big
in the news
- Yoda was like okay what do something
generation people when you buy things
security hundreds of people died it was
said because a lot of these newer cars
have a lot of really cool features that
they have I know that you like a lot of
those features is it enough is that fear
enough to make you want to go maybe
lower tech in a car maybe older that
doesn't have a lot of these features in
there anyone you think about why a car
was built it's to get you from point A
to point B all these luxury it additives
thank you they're nice put now yeah
great look great my wallet says
otherwise but nice and toasty just think
about that like all the Tesla's now and
having autopilot like my roommate has a
Tesla and he'd literally like will be
writing emails on his laptop while car
just is driving itself a car with that
situation and I'm just like this is
[ __ ] creepy yeah I feel like it
depends on the company to like if it's
not like software first company its I
don't know man I don't know about
trusting that like [ __ ] Ford's chip
yes come on guys but that's the whole
reason why now it's like an additional
kind of service to have security for
that you buy like the Norton AntiVirus
for your car or something well sometimes
it's so easy so it's just like yeah I
don't know more money throw more money
at the problem now I'm not gonna pay for
it but that's great you don't need to
with you Jeep but you got to install
games and stuff on your computer at one
point no but the thing is like warranty
are we talking what Tesla no I think it
was like man there is I think it was
yeah I mean is is that you actually
install games normally yeah no I mean
before like before yeah before you know
what's crazy is that there's like DLCs
poor Tesla yeah my again I room it had
one at the time then I was living with
him and all of a sudden the car had this
new feature that like had never he never
had before and it was a there's like
sport mode extreme mode and in like
superstore yeah yeah there's like an
extreme and there was like a super sport
that downloaded on his car randomly and
apparently it's it's because like the
engine is electrical yeah so you can
have it run harder yeah I mean that's
every uh now almost no engines are like
not run by computers now it's also like
it's not like Tesla's one of the few
companies that's doing like that it's
like a downloadable package like
otherwise if you get something like that
for a gas engine you have to buy which
more cars actually had getting your
update because I view some cars when if
you're not putting on sport mode it
[ __ ] sucks I believe an update like
real bad Maseratis look at you terrible
they should go the easy route yeah I
think we're Tesla's that they're mainly
just like a tech company first before
cars and they do make cars but the cars
are just this giant piece of tech yeah
that's why they can do all these updates
I like how you can like turn on the air
conditioner in the Tesla and that's what
sacrifice security for
[Music]